What is a good protocol for addressing chemo-induced peripheral neuropathy?
I do own a rebuilder.
Are there nutraceuticals that could help rebuild nerves?
Do you recommend acupuncture?
How long does a tick does PEMF help?
Do products like Bieber help or the ISIS PEMF device?
So the Bieber and the ISIS are PEMF devices.
They're just low-gouse PEMF devices.
And then there's devices like the pulse,
which are high-go-gouse PEMF devices.
Any PEMF device is going to help.
The rebuilder is going to be best because it's
going to be stimulating the nerves at their own frequencies.
Derbs grow back and heal at only about a millimeter a day.
I don't know if there's any new data on that,
but that's what I learned years ago when I was in school.
So it's a slow process.
So chemo-induced neuropathy is death of the neurons
because of the chemotherapy.
So chemotherapy is a toxic substance that can kill rapidly
replicating cells.
And it can damage neurons.
And it can stay in harbor and peripheral areas.
That's why you end up with peripheral neuropathy.
Because you have less blood flow, poor circulation,
poor lip drainage, peripherally.
So how do you get rid of that?
Well, you try to do everything you can to help move circulation.
So exercise is going to be key to that.
Hot cold circulation, stimulation of the nerves.
Anyway, you possibly can.
Remember your nerves, the end point of a nerve.
Or we should say the beginning point of an a-ferrant nerve.
So a-ferrant is, you know, you prick your finger out.
So that's an a-ferrant communication
that prick of the finger stimulates receptors
on your skin surface.
Those receptors fire up your arm and to your brain.
So that is an a-ferrant pathway.
So would you have neuropathy, do you have no feeling,
or you have pain, or you have tingleed?
These are a-ferrant nerves that are damaged.
An a-ferrant nerve would be a nerve that's
controlling muscle function.
So that's coming from the brain down to that area.
So it's the a-ferrant pathways, what are called the large diameter a-ferrant pathways,
that are damaged in peripheral neuropathy.
So the more you could do to stimulate those nerves, the better.
I think I have a video on the, I think I have the video,
I know it's on the rebuilder ad or the rebuilders of the store
under the rebuilder.
I think I have a video where I explained to a couple staff people,
the large diameter a-ferrant pathway, et cetera.
But just to state it again more succinctly,
would be that these receptors at the skin surface
are primarily hot and cold receptors,
vibration receptors, and pain receptors.
So any way that you can stimulate those receptors
are going to stimulate growth and healing of that nerve.
So nerves work on a, you know, you use it or lose it basis.
So the more you can stimulate that neural pathway,
the more that you're going to grow that neural pathway.
So that's, you know, how the rebuilder works,
it's using electrical stimulation at the frequency of the nerve
to help build that pathway.
But also you can stimulate the other receptors.
So you have it a little vibration plate.
You can buy a little vibration plate for your feet.
That's at a slant where it's made to sit in front of a chair
while you're sitting watching TV, and you put your feet on it
with your socks on, and it's helped.
They're made to feel comfortable on your feet.
But that stimulation that vibration helps rebuild
nerve pathways.
It's actually really good for your brain.
It's really good for neurology.
So just put in your feet out of there and stimulating
that those pathways can help rebuild that.
Put in your feet in hot and cold water,
stimulating those pathways.
Walking outside barefoot, walking out and down a gravel driveway.
Oh gosh, it's painful.
It hurts.
Well, keep doing it.
You will build up calluses.
The more you can stimulate those nerves,
the more you can stimulate your brain.
So it's not only good for the peripheral neuropathy.
It's a good brain-based therapy for your brain
to keep your brain alive.
So your brain is just a conglomeration of neurons.
So the more you can stimulate those neurons,
the better off it's going to be.
And you can stimulate them through peripheral receptors,
primarily pain, hot and cold vibration.
And the better it's going to be for those neurons,
that if you're a pathway, and your brain.
So you are also helping keep your brain alive
by doing this as well.
So the PEMF is just using electrical stimulation
the same way.
So the more you could do the PEMF,
the acupuncture, similar to.
So is acupuncture good?
Yeah, that can help.
I would say, sure, chiropractic, getting chiropractic adjustments,
that could help too.
The more stimulation on your surface of your body,
the more stimulation of the muscles,
the better off you're going to be.
Then from a nutritional chemistry side,
the more you could help move the lymph,
the better off it's going to be.
Remember lymph moves by action of the muscles.
The lymph does not have a heart pushing it through.
The lymph system is a vascular system
that has valves in it every few centimeters.
And you need motion in order to move lymph
through that tissue to help get rid of the toxins,
the poisons from the chemotherapy.
And then you need to detox these things.
So once it gets into the lymph system,
it goes into the vascular system.
And it goes through the liver.
And the liver has to go through phase 1, 2, 3, detox pathways.
So remember, go back to the seven phases of detox course
to learn more about that.
Anything you do to help support liver pathways,
the better off you're going to be.
That's kind of a little overview of that, help that helps.